alors cette semaine aussi 17 une pléiade
de coups de coeur c'est à dire 10 coups
de coeur mais je vais aller très vite
d'abord le festival télérama du 24 au 30
janvier
donc on vous propose cette semaine neuf
très grands films je les cite juste
rapidement mais vous pouvez tous venir
les voir les yeux fermés ce sont
vraiment de grands films pour les
enfants le grand méchant renard patients
sans un vêtement par minute
le caire confidentielles évidemment tous
les films étrangers sont en vo une vie
violente
the lost city of z la villa de
guédiguian faute d'amour à voir
absolument et en avant-première razia et
deuxième coup de coeur pour un film que
je n'ai pas encore vu mais je peux le
faire les yeux fermés c'est pentagon
papers de steven spielberg
donc c'est son 10e film historique comme
chacun sait je vous en dirai plus
probablement la prochaine fois mais je
pense que c'est un film très intéressant
qui raconte une histoire une partie de
l'histoire politique des états unis
ça court sur quatre présidents américain
et ça raconte l'histoire de la rivalité
entre le washington post et puis un
autre grand journal américain sur fond
de guerre du vietnam donc énième
collaboration entre steven spielberg et
tom hanks
meryl streep aussi nommé président ce
quart pour venez voir le film en vo et
en vf
cette semaine aussi 17